during that point what did i do is I did
what I preached to all of you which is I
put in the work I gave up all my
weekends and holidays in high school
because I knew I had to pay that price
because I wasn't going to do the I'm
going to go to school meet some good
kids at Stanford and brown Ivy League
school make some relationships and
that's going to be my springboard I was
going to start with no relationships and
in the gutter and I was gonna have to
prove it and I would have to show up and
meet everybody like I did in my 30s but
in my teens and 20s I was going to work
and so what I did was to the extreme of
anybody I've met that had options some
people lose their father mother welfare
but anybody who had some options I
punted every leisure activity in my life
nothing no weekends
no vacations zero nothing nothing like
we're making jokes about the seven days
I didn't take a single and by the way
yeah but like but it's my truth I didn't
take a single vacation day never and I'm
sure you've worked on your Sinus I just
love you and I don't want to razz you
like none zero zero zero all my high
school friends gone because I wasn't
around all my college friends
post-college gone I'd see them a little
bit I love those guys but God
girlfriends nothing all-in
so what I do I've worked I worked to
such an extreme level that when I push
you on work I don't even ask you to do
50 percent of what I did and I guarantee
you'll [ __ ] win